HARISH JAYAKUMAR:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to our session,
and today we're
going to be talking about how
to enhance your security posture
and run PCI compliant
application with Anthos.
I'm Harish Jayakumar.
I lead the Application
Modernization team
here at Google Cloud.
And today, with me, I have Ann.
ANN WALLACE: Hi, I'm Ann
Wallace, Security Solution
Manager with Google Cloud.
HARISH JAYAKUMAR:
Thank you, Ann.
Let's jump in.
So when we talk about
running regulated workloads,
it can get quite
complex, especially
because there are
multiple stakeholders that
are involved in it.
On one side you have
the makers, that's
the developers, the product
owners, and the enterprise
architects.
And on the other side,
you have the checkers,
which are the security teams,
risk and compliance team,
and the legal teams as well.
So because of
these complexities,
regulated workloads
are the slowest ones
to move to the Cloud,
or even to modernize.
So in this talk, we're
going to be exploring
how to modernize these
workloads, at the same time,
meet the compliance
requirements that either need
to be on Google Cloud, or
if you want to run them
on prem using Anthos.
Now, running a regulated
workload, especially for PCI
in this case, what we're
talking about with this one,
is challenging.
Because audits can
be quite daunting.
Why?
One, compliance
frameworks were not
built for cloud
native architectures.
Two, it actually takes a
village to pass an audit
and demonstrate the
compliance associated with it.
Then three, you want to also
avoid misconfigurations.
And if there are any, you have
to fix that And then finally,
evidencing a shared
responsibility, especially
today when we talk with
customers, most of them
either have hybrid model or
they're on multiple clouds,
so understanding that
shared responsibility
becomes very, very important.
Which brings you to
the slide where we are.
How does this fit into the
shared responsibility model?
So when we're looking
at simply, for example,
running Anthos on Google
Cloud, or if you're
running Anthos on prem, you can
see the difference over there.
Simply running on Anthos
Cloud, you see a lot of it
is actually handed to
you by Google itself.
And the customer
only needs to focus
on the application, some
configuration associated
with that, and some base images.
Whereas the picture
completely changes when
you move to Anthos on prem.
It is much more
controlled, the customer
has to take care
of [? updating ?]
the node hardware, the
networking, the storage,
and the physical hosting.
So we need to be able to see,
for example, if something
happens, something goes wrong,
who's responsible for it.
Let's take an example,
for example, when
an identity management is done.
Whereas on the Google
Cloud, you can actually
leverage the Google Cloud, and
[? then repeat ?] some form
on the other with
Cloud IAM, and then we
can handle that for you.
So customers are
starting to adopt
Anthos to build the next
generation digital platforms,
modernizing the security for
cloud native deployments is
a great use case where
they're actually using it.
And the key objectives
for those modernizations,
are one, increasing the
developer productivity
through the use of containers
and micro services,
while adopting
hybrid and multicloud
as deployment platforms.
Many of these customers
process sensitive data
that include PII, PCI, and PHI.
Further, they must also meet
the regulatory compliance.
But as application teams
adopt new technology stacks
and development processes,
using the existing paradigms
and processes is no longer
optimal or even sufficient.
So in order to deliver
the developer agility,
the security stack
also needs to evolve
to align with the new
development and [? product ?]
processes.
It must also address new threats
that apply to modern production
environments.
Now, let's pivot quickly to
the compliance requirements.
So we've taken some of
the compliance frameworks,
such as NIST 800-53, which
maps to [INAUDIBLE],, PCI DSS,
ISO 27001, and have identified
some common technical
requirements.
They actually fall into
these five categories--
segmentation and isolation,
identity access management,
data security, supply
chain, application security.
Now, we don't have time
to dive into all these
in this 25 minutes
talk, but we will
talk about how Anthos
can help with several
of these requirements
right out of the box.
As you can see, the
same five requirements,
we have put them down
into five pillars.
And out of the
box, Anthos offers
a lot of security capabilities.
Each control aligns with the
common compliance requirements
that we talked about
in the previous slide,
whether it's going to be
segmentation networking, IAM
data security and encryption,
secure supply chain,
and application security.
So as you can see,
most of these features
to help you achieve
your security posture.
But as I mentioned before,
it's the shared responsibility
model, and you need to know how
to blend the controls together
appropriately and understand
what you are responsible for.
For that, what we we're
going to be introducing
is Anthos Blueprints.
And to talk in
detail about that,
I'd like to call back Ann.
Ann?
ANN WALLACE: Cool,
thanks Harish.
So before we dive into
the Anthos Blueprints,
first, let's talk about
our security blueprint.
So we've designed
security blueprint
to help some of this
complexity that Harish
described, to simplify it.
So the first
security blueprint we
have is called a
security posture.
So this is a collection
of resources and code
that deliver granular
and specific security
postures to a workload, such
as maybe a customer facing
application or back end process.
For example, securing data,
or securing API endpoints.
The next one that we offer
is called a landing zone.
So this is a
pre-configured environment
with a standard set of secure
cloud Infrastructure, policy,
and guidelines.
So this can be something that's
otherwise very complicated
to set up and might take
months of investigation,
implementation by
trial and error
to get right the first time.
So an example, this
PCI for Anthos.
Regardless of the type
of security blueprint,
they're all designed to
be easy to use and deploy.
And we also employ all
of Google Cloud Security
best practices in
the blueprints.
So you can say they're
secure by default.
So one of the first security
landing zones that we released
was PCI on GKE, and coming
soon as PIC on Anthos.
So these help customers
get started with compliance
on Anthos quicker.
So it also allows you to
quickly and easily deploy
workloads on Anthos that align
to PCI DSS in a repeatable,
supported, and secure way.
So let's look at
everything that's
included in the blueprint.
So the PCI on Anthos
Blueprint contains
many opinionated reference
architecture diagrams
depicting the infrastructure
and application deployment.
While they're intended to be
used with deployable assets,
they also show you
how to create diagrams
of your containerized
cardholder data environments,
and the boundaries between PCI
and non-PCI workloads, which
is a requirement in PCI audits.
The Blueprint also contains
different deployable assets.
And then we also include
PCI DSS 3.2.1 mappings
to the solutions, and a
compliance white paper.
So with our Anthos
on GCP Blueprint,
we provide you with
Terraform templates
to set up your infrastructure.
These include org
policies, projects, VPCs,
and GKE clusters.
And as Harish described
about the shift in the shared
responsibility model,
on prem we only
provide you with
reference architectures
for squares one and two.
But with both of
the blueprints, we
provide you with service mesh
profiles, GKE configurations,
ACM policies, and
then a demo app
to test out the environment
configuration and setup.
So let's pivot to segmentation.
There are two types
of segmentation.
So the first one is
macro segmentation.
So these are things that
you do outside the cluster.
So you segment the
users, networks,
and applications using
different Google Cloud features
and tools.
This really helps you set
aside the scope of the audit.
And then we have
micro segmentation.
So these are things that
you do inside the cluster.
So let's double click
on that a little bit.
So with GKE micro segmentation,
we offer many ways to do this.
So we have network policies.
This helps with layer 3 and
4 network level segmentation.
Then we have GKE namespaces
for virtual clusters
to segment teams, or
maybe app versus prod,
or app dev versus prod.
Then we have GKE
private clusters,
so you have clusters
of private IP space.
And then Anthos service mesh.
Then the net net here
is there are many ways
to do micro segmentation
in a cluster.
So for the PCI on Anthos
on prem blueprint,
the first layer of
segmentation is addressed
through separate clusters.
So we create two clusters,
two user clusters,
one for in-scope, or for
your cardholder data cluster,
and then one for the
out-of-scope workloads.
And then building
upon the segmentation,
we have segmented out of
the pods within a cluster,
but you further need to
demonstrate separation
of maybe dev and test
versus prod environments
to your auditor, or you need to
segment application profiles.
So this is where you would
use different namespaces.
And then oftentimes, you're
presented with a requirement
to protect the routing
information and the private IP
spaces.
This is where you mark
a cluster as private.
And such a cluster
and the master
become inaccessible from
the public internet.
And then the nodes in
the private cluster
do not have public IP addresses.
So the admin and
user clusters are
private for the on prem
blueprint and the GCP
blueprint.
So looking at some of the
reference architectures that
are provided as part
of this blueprint,
you can see here that again,
the in-scope and out-of-scope
cluster separation.
And then we have
Anthos Service Mesh,
so it's a single mesh
for multi clusters.
And then our demo app is
called Online Boutique.
So this is an e-commerce micro
services demo application.
So this allows you to
test out the controls
and the architecture.
The PCI DSS audit
burden is minimized
by moving the micro services
from that demo application that
don't touch payment card data
into the out-of-scope cluster.
This reference architecture
details this layout.
This also helps you with
your own architectures
and documentation.
And then looking
more specifically at
PCI requirements.
So PCI requirement four
talks about encrypting
data in flight, specifically
of cardholder data
across open and public networks.
For our on prem blueprint,
the in-scope and out-of-scope
clusters are in
separate networks,
which helps with strong
isolation for PCI boundaries.
This also means that the cross
cluster communication must
go through a Istio gateway.
All cross customer communication
uses mutual TLS authentication
and encryption.
Citadel is also
included for managing
the internal certificates.
So a lot of the blueprint
is for day zero,
but we also want to talk
about day one and day
two sort of scenarios.
So this is where policy as
code or shifting left happen.
So setting up initially
is great, everything's PCI
compliant.
But as you're deploying
new containers or new code
into your environment,
how do you make sure
these meet PCI requirements?
So to help with this, we
have binary authorization,
Anthos Config Management,
and Anthos Policy Controller.
So let's look at these in
a little bit more detail.
So for a requirements such
as establish a process
to identify security
vulnerabilities,
you can use Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning.
So this checks the
images that you
push into the registry for
known security vulnerabilities.
It is constantly refreshing
its vulnerability database
by ingesting corresponding
vendor security feeds,
so that you can be notified
of new vulnerabilities that
maybe previously
affected scan containers.
You can also tie this in with
Pub/Sub to get notifications,
so you can integrate this
in with your CICD process,
or file bugs for newly
discovered vulnerabilities.
And another requirement
is to ensure all systems
and software are protected
from known vulnerabilities.
This is where binary
authorization can help.
So it ensures that
only properly signed
containers are deployed
into production
or other environments.
You can use binary authorization
to create deployment policies
based on container
image metadata.
So these policies can
be based on attestation,
such as a vulnerability scan,
or other types of signatures,
such as maybe being built
by a particular pipeline,
or having gone through
a specific QA process.
Again, this ensures that only
trusted images are deployed
into your environments.
So let's put all this together.
So when code is checked into
GitHub or your source code
repository, it triggers
a a build in Cloud Build.
Cloud Build then generates
a new container image.
It will create a build record
that contains information
on the image, including the
location, the source code
from which the image was built.
And then that triggers
a vulnerability scan.
So the vulnerability
scan is done, the results
of that scan are stored
as part of the metadata
for that container.
And as mentioned on
the previous slide,
you can configure
binary authorization
to require attestation based on
the vulnerability scan results.
So this prevents images
with known vulnerabilities
beyond a certain level, so maybe
say high, from being deployed.
You can also have
other requirements,
like only allowing images
from trusted sources.
So if someone
tries to deploy one
of these unauthorized
images, binary authorization
will stop it, and all of this
is logged in Cloud Audit Log.
So now Anthos Config
Management, or ACM.
So with ACM, you can create
common configurations
across all your infrastructure,
including custom policies,
and apply it to both on
prem and across clouds.
Anthos Config Management
evaluates the changes
and rolls them out to all
the Kubernetes clusters,
so that your desired
state is always reflected.
And so based on Open
Policy Agent's Gateway,
ACM Policy Controller provides
first class integration
between OPA and Kubernetes
via a custom controller.
So this turns Rego policies
into Kubernetes objects,
allowing them to be
customized and deployed
using your standard workflows.
When policy controller
is configured,
incoming objects can be denied
admission into your cluster,
or audited to see if they
violate governance policies.
So we offer quite a
few sample policies
that you can use with ACM.
They include policies
like required services
to disable unauthorized
access, or label enforcement.
But more specifically, with
our Anthos PCI Blueprint,
we include policies
to help enforce TLS.
And again, this helps
enforce PCI requirement four,
which talks about
encrypting data in transit,
specifically of cardholder
data across open and public
networks.
So as you can see
from this slide,
looking at some other
common controls,
we can see how services
like binary authorization
or Policy Controller and Anthos
Config Management can help.
And then lastly, we tie
all of this together
by mapping the
various components
and policies in the
blueprint to PCI DSS 3.2.1.
And we also include
a PCI white paper.
So the white paper provides
an independent third party
assessment of the blueprint
performed by PCI auditors.
This not only gives you, our
customers, more confidence
in our solution.
It is also something that
you can provide your QSA
as part of your audit, which
hopefully will help speed up
your assessment.
So to learn more about this, or
our other Blueprint, schedule
a session with your Google team.
Or check out the links here.
So there's one for
Google Cloud and PCI,
and one for our
security blueprints.
Thank you.